- [Narrator] In the 1950s, wearing denim
made you a rebel without a cause.
And mainstream acceptance
lagged until one of the world's
most famous crooners
challenged the status quo.
In 1951, American singer Bing Crosby
tried to check into a
swanky Canadian hotel.
Like many entertainers of the day,
he was decked head to toe in denim
so the hotel tried to turn him away.
- [Man] You don't belong here.
- [Narrator] Luckily, a
bellhop recognized him.
- [Man] Hey that's Bing Crosby.
- [Narrator] And the singer checked in.
(ringing)
Word of this denim dilemma
in Canada got back to Levi's.
- [Man] Uh-huh, uh-huh, done.
(hangs up)
- [Narrator] So the
company sprang into action.
They developed a custom
denim jacket for Bing Crosby.
It was decorated with
Levi's signature red tags
and a large leather patch
labeling the denim as a tuxedo.
(singing)
Crosby rocked the new look,
and from that moment forward
denim fashion was never the same again.
(light music)